>From an engineering perspective,
chronic disease presents
a data logistics problem.
Here's a more dramatic network
depiction of the complex,
highly specialist-driven care of
the chronic disease patients in
the typical primary care
physician's practice.
As you already know, the average
multi-chronic disease patient,
20% of Medicare patients that drive
half of the cost is seen each
year by 14 providers who are mostly
specialists, as shown here.
In aggregate, all of
the multi-chronic disease patients in
a typical PCP's practice
are seen by 86 providers.
Again, mostly specialists.
Keep in mind that each of these
specialists mostly focuses only on
the particular organ or body system
they have special knowledge of, and
are trained to treat.
In total, the average PCP is involved
with over 200 other providers.